welcome to another edition of a beginner
breakdown I'm your host Mike Hummer
thank you all in the live audience for
coming and today we'll be going over how
to defeat the perc defense are the
Sicilian dragon so both are very kind of
similar because black setup will be fee
on Kettering the bishop along the long
diagonal here and there's very good ways
for white to just go on the attack right
away and checkmate the blacks King so
here we go so white starts out efore
black plays c5 so this will be the
Sicilian defense white counters Knight
of three black plays d6 white goes for
the center with d4 takes takes black
plays Knight of six keeping this options
open for you know getting this Bishop
either here or here still undetermined
at this point but now he's attacking our
pawn so we can just simply defend it
with Knight to c3 all right so we're
defended and so now black makes the
choice to play is pawn to g6 considering
it would take 1 well you could play a 6
followed by Bishop e7 but he decides
it'll go with g6 and this will start the
Sicilian dragon so white plays Bishop to
e3 because his idea is to put the Queen
and Bishop in a battery and then attack
this h6 Square but by playing Bishop to
e3 right now it lets black try to try to
make this bishop
and queen battery never happened what
move can whiten may our black make it's
black move to get this bishop off of III
yes adjourned alright but we're looking
at a way to it to harass this Bishop
right now yes night yeah Knight to g4
would attack this Bishop so now he would
have to move this Bishop again and if he
didn't if he played Queen to d2 then we
could just take and Queen takes and now
Bishop here and now nobody is going to
be able to harass this bishop anymore
okay so if you're playing on the black
side of this Sicilian defense or pert
defense you would want to you would love
to trade this night for this Bishop
because if this bishops gone then your
dark squared Bishop will be there to
stay on g7 okay but black just proceeds
with his own plan of Bishop to g7 so now
white plays f3 to stop all that all that
from happening but he wanted to prepare
prepare that move Bishop to e3 by
playing f3 first so he just got the move
order in correct so black castles Queen
to d2 so when the Queen and Bishop or on
the same diagonal it's called a battery
so if anybody ever if you hear about
batteries that's what it means they're
on the same diagonal that's a good
question
yeah yeah I've heard of rook and Queen
battery yep when they're on the same
same line yep so Knight to c6
so now black is setting up white for a
trap here so he knows that he wants to
put his bishop on e6
but would that be good right now to do
that even though that's his plan the
answer is no because the night could
come down and take his night and then if
I would take back Bishop takes or he's
got even better because if the night
takes here Bishop takes this would just
win a pawn for uh for black so black is
even better when he plays Bishop to h6
which would be wicked black play to get
the most amount of material right now
adjourn Bishop takes h6 because I have
to take back and now I get the whole
night for free because in this position
Bishop takes h6 if I take here I'm
threatening the Queen but unfortunately
the bishop will take giving me check so
it would be illegal for my knight to
take the Queen okay so so I cannot play
my Bishop to h6 right now cuz he would
you would simply take it and then win my
knight
so what move should white play to
eliminate that threat Hey
alright as a yeah from their audience
they said just take the knight all right
so Bishop to h6 but now this B file is
open so black is going to attack it and
try to get some counter play here so
white decides to live on the edge here
and castle into this danger zone so now
black and threatened a checkmate and
it's always good to threaten checkmate
with Queen to b6 threatening Queen takes
b2 checkmate all right
white prepares he plays b3 here and now
this is getting tricky because now Queen
goes to b4 and like in the last lecture
we did a couple weeks ago we saw aloud
all these all these good tricks along
the long diagonal here so a lot of a lot
of tricky things he can do because he's
threatening a check and then if if
everything else is away you could put
his queen on b2 if this if the both
nights are gone it would be checkmate so
he's got to watch out for that kind of
stuff so white plays King to b2 which is
unfortunate because the knight can come
down and maybe do something dangerous
here to exploit this pin does he have
any tricks here let's look
and I don't see any tricks does anybody
see any tricks
good because black didn't see any tricks
either in this position Bishop h6 queen
takes yeah that's what actually is
played in the game he decides he decides
he doesn't see any of these these knight
tricks so he decides just to eliminate
the threat Queen takes h6 so now blacks
plan should be to play a five and a four
and try to get a checkmate that way okay
say you plays Bishop to e6 here so now
black has a good attack going it bring
even better with a five a four so now
white really needs to get his attack
going as quick as possible
or else he's gonna get checkmated
alright so white decides he'll start
with g4 h4 is the more conventional way
h4 h5 but Whitesides g4 black proceeds
with c5 and white plays h4 now if I'm
playing if if if I was playing as the
black pieces here I would just proceed
with the plan right cuz if Bishop takes
that loses the Bishop Bishop takes and I
cannot take back because my piece is in
a pin okay so I would just proceed with
the plan okay same thing with a5 a4 if
black played a5 and then got a four in
let's just say he does this and that my
I can't take here because Queen takes
and then this pawn is in a pen
okay so that's why that a five a four is
pretty strong but after C five black
plays a mystery move rook to a eight
after after white play h4 he he plays
rook to a eight and he doesn't need to
do that because the the pawn doesn't
need any backing up because he's in no
and no concern that his pawns gonna get
captured on a four it should it should
be there it should be fine so why can't
capture it if he does he'll lose a
knight so so he didn't his attack is too
slow right now you want to be as fast as
you can when you're attacking all right
all right so my my he let my attack
catch up with his because he's dawdling
around with this rook and this other
pawn or rook to e8 so white plays h5 and
now black plays a5 but it's too slow so
now pawn takes if it takes this way the
game would be over everybody see how the
game would be over
Queen to h8 checkmate okay so he has to
take back the other way
alright so so now you ask yourself why
am I not checkmating him why is Queen
takes h7 not checkmate
yes adjourn because the knight would
take the Queen okay so you need to be
asking yourself questions like this
during the game like dang I wish that it
could happen how can I make it happen
so in ideas I'm going to attack the
knight attack the piece that's giving
you the most trouble that's aggravating
you so you would you you attack the
knight but now he goes here all right
so now your queen is kind of can't move
to anywhere that she won't get taken so
so now but now but where you can just
take a night so we calculate okay so we
took a five point piece the rook for a
three point piece but we saw when after
he takes the rook we can take the bishop
with check yeah so would we're doing
good yeah so we just traded a five five
point piece but we got two of his minor
pieces and now we're back on the attack
with with the check all right
King h8 so we might as well just keep
keep taking more stuff so now he plays a
four and we're not gonna do the same
move he did or else you know we'll lose
a knight even if we right yeah yeah but
we want to watch out cuz we might get
checkmated yeah we might get checkmated
that's why he wouldn't do a four well
we're not gonna play that we're not
gonna play that let's see what we do
play we just take another pawn queen
takes d6 rook takes f3
alright so now he's threatening to take
us no going back we're going back no
going back in this position so so in
this position after Queen takes right
instead of taking this pawn a3 with the
check we'd be pretty strong because King
moves Queen takes and now he's
threatening a checkmate that we might
not be able to get out of
so you got to watch out for these up
these attacks so some night take say for
what's the correct move after all after
all right but but luckily he took there
and now now we can try to win this rook
up here or try to get a checkmate d5
check King to g8 so Queen to d5 check
would win the rook but white once to get
a checkmate here so luckily he doesn't
go back to force the draw
he plays King to e7 and that allows
another one of my pieces to get involved
in the checkmate process and that would
be the rook rook the d7 check King g6
and now how can we end them we actually
have two Queen - which one
but fortunately if we play Queen 2d6 you
can you can take Queen to g7
checkmate okay yep yeah you just look
through your checks and say oh well I
could play here but he could take and
that would just look and then I'm still
protecting this pawn through an x-ray
yeah so so in the games you've got to
watch out for these checkmates here yeah
this is a very very common common attack
here where a three check Queen takes so
white needed to be a little more careful
but he was just lucky that black really
slowed down his attack by moving his
rook over and then didn't capitalize
when he saw it now we get an idea of how
to checkmate somebody when they're
playing the perk defense or the sicilian
dragon so so now we'll put a put another
game up there that's very similar and
and you guys should be just shouting out
these moves very very fast okay
so white plays efore black proceeds c5
the Sicilian Knight f3 d6 d4 pawn takes
Knight captures Knight f6 so even though
we're in a hurry to to you know get our
Bishop out and everything we always have
to be respecting our opponent's moves
Knight to c3 g6 so Bishop to e3 remember
is that a good move or do we have a
better way to prepare Bishop to e3 yes
we should prepare it with f3 okay that
prevents this knife from coming in but
black kind of has his own plans that's a
lot of times in chess
you're like oh I'm playing this opening
I'm gonna play the Sicilian drag and
okay and he knows Oh
by playing the Sicilian journey i just
got my bishop i'll get castle
everything's good but by speeding
through the opening like that he's
missing ideas to eliminate this night so
so just because you think you know the
opening really well make sure you you're
paying attention to your opponent's
threats so Bishop to g7 or his mistakes
then you can capitalize on Bishop the g7
now f3 black castles Queen to d2 Bishop
to d7 so Bishop h6 so we got our Queen
and Bishop battery and we got our bishop
on h6 so things are going good Knight to
c6 just like in the other game he wants
to take so we'll take and then I'll get
the free night so whenever they do that
we can we can just take where we got we
can't just sit there and do nothing we
have to we have to do something so we
can take and now the bishop takes white
decide and you could I mean it's it's
interchangeable you could take whichever
piece you want at first it really
doesn't matter as long as you do
something as long as you capture one of
them you won't lose any pieces so now so
now white decides to play g4 first cuz
if he plays h4 black encounter with h5
okay this is a very typical idea for
blacks defense okay that prevents g4 cuz
black takes takes and then black and
take that and then he beat up a pawn
okay so so white plays g4 to stop him
from playing h5 black plays ecigs
white castle's so he did that it's not
often you Castille and you get a threat
so by castling what move can can white
play now you can take the pawn on d6
okay because the rook is helping
protecting the Queen
so black decides to defend with 98 and
that cuts off the connection between his
queen and rook and now his Knight is a
permanent defender and also the knight
is no longer defending h5 and it's no
longer on the attack at all so that's
really not a not a great spot for that
night you want your pieces out there
doing stuff not just on the back row
defending not very strong piece all
right so why proceed with the attack h4
black counters Queen to e7 just keep
pushing those pawns up
rook to d8 gets another defender on this
pawn so now white decides to just get
another pawn in the attack before before
he taking so black plays Knight to c7 so
now takes pawn F takes Bishop c4 attacks
the pawn
a six so now White's gonna try to try to
get all his pieces down there that f4
kind of wasn't really good for his plan
because he really wanted to get his
queen up there so f4 kind of kind of
blocking him he needs to push f5 to get
this a queen check in there to h2 b5
attacks the bishop he decides to play a
double his rooks and attack here so how
should black defend this yes you work to
h8 Matt as well good rook to h8 so now
he's got a you can't forget that as
there's bishops being attacked so so
he'll retreat it he doesn't want to take
it and now blacks getting some counter
player d5 pawn takes d5 pawn takes d5
and now I finally gets an f5 threatening
Queen to h5 check Queen to h6 check
excuse me so when black plays d4 and
gets the check in black is going to be
in a lot of trouble here
so King to f6 the move that was played
in the game was g5 check and now the
King is on the run King takes up five
rook to f1 check King to e5 and now he's
in a lot of trouble huh
so the Queen and King when they're in
the same line you want to get another
piece in that same line so who you think
rook check ok so the king queen er ever
lined up try to get a rook in there okay
if they're lying up on the same diagonal
get a bishop in there all right King
King moves rook takes King takes and
it's not over yet for for black he's not
out of the woods yet Queen the g7 check
King to d6 then you get the rook in
there and now now in this position black
just gave it up what do you think
White's next move would have been
now if I would have just taken the night
huh well that's okay that's okay so if
we play Queen to e7 here
unfortunately the king can go back here
and protect the night where the simplest
solution is just to capture the night
and just say good night you like it yeah
actually it's not good night
he's still getting away a3 now can we
say good night and take the pawn take
the pawn with checkmate okay so so in
that game white kind of messed up his
attack huh so this is the point where
white messed up his attack by playing f4
it took him a really long time to
recover he should have just captured
right away pawn takes right you want to
take and now Queen check okay that's
what you're going for they move f4 kind
of stopped it stopped this whole attack
here check and now you're doing pretty
good this is probably a lot better
variation than uh than the one that he
went into all right and then you can
just try to pile on on these pieces okay
so you don't really want to block your
Queen off of that h6 square by playing
f4 okay here's the final game and we'll
see if we can find a quick checkmate in
the middle game in this one
unfortunately the white player in this
game did not all right but maybe we can
be better than him all right so so we
were looking at games
coming out of the Sicilian the last two
games
the Sicilian dragon
this is a more conventional pert defense
where black does not play c5 he starts
out with d6 as we saw that was blacks
second move in all those variations so
this is the part defense
whenever somebody plays a move like d6
or eise Ickx or c6 a move that does not
attack you know
efore or d4 in your position should
always just play d4 and that way you got
the whole center to yourself okay nine
up six attacks are pawned so we bring
our knight g6 Bishop e3 again so nice
should jump right in so so always make
sure when you're playing white to play
that f3 move first or else you know
eventually black might come down and
play Knight to g4 and attack you out of
there all right Queen little black
castles so that's it that's a great
thing about this perk defense and the
Sicilian dragon is you get castle very
very quick and look you have a lot of
defenders around your king but
unfortunately White has some good good
attacking chances okay so you got to
take the good and the bad when you play
the perk defense or just Sicilian a
dragon so these are just ways that white
can try to take advantage of them Queen
to d2 c6 so as we've seen time and time
again the bishop goes to h6 he wants to
trade this dark squared bishop
he's like the fire of the Dragon okay
because if he sticks around as we saw in
some of the previous games if he sticks
around he can be forced and to possibly
get the the knight the pawn or the rook
okay so that's why white is so eager to
trade off these dark squared bishop so
kay
so black plays ePHI he doesn't trade so
white takes King takes like g2e to
defending the pawn Queen to b6
attacks the pawn and so now with this
Queen to b6 move he's attacking this
pawn and he's attacking this pawn twice
white only has well White's got enough
defenders so he decides the castle that
brings a defender to this B 2 square and
another defender to d4 all right
brings his night out so once again he
doesn't want to play h4 cuz black a
counter h5 ok so you prepare that move
with g4 pawn takes d4 and of course if
our idea is white is to checkmate the
black king right Queen h6 and get
checkmate we don't want to trade our
queen so Knight takes alright whenever
you got an attack going do not trade
attackers or also be nobody there to
checkmate at the end black plays 95 so
it's threatening the pawn here so just
protect and now your Brooks are
connected black counters with d5
so white plays g5 eliminating a defender
of d5 here so when he plays Knight back
to e8 you can take pawn takes knight six
and now he's winning a pawn and
attacking the Queen so things are going
well for white here
very well so Queen to c5 and now white
decides to play Queen to f4 all right so
what is the trick here what is white
hoping black plays in this position
Queen takes Knight Queen takes the
undefended Knight
okay so is this a good move for black to
play Queen takes Knight or is it just
devastation bad move right because this
rook is attacking this Queen through an
x-ray meaning if this Knight moves and
for some reason this Queen is is not
allowed to move in the next move he's
going to take it and the only way for a
piece not to be allowed to move or
frozen is if he's in check so white has
two checks with the knight
you better be careful which one you pick
cuz one one is good one is bad all right
go for it
Knight to f5 is the correct move Knight
a5 check Bishop takes rook takes
unfortunately if you play Knight to e6
check Queen can take the knight and then
the rook cannot capture the Queen so you
got to watch out for that okay so so now
is black he knows I can't take the
knight so he's got to got to figure out
something else to do so he decides to
put his knight on c6 hero
Knight to f6 Knight captures d4 rook
takes d4 Bishop to f5 so now who is
threatening checkmate here black is okay
obviously I'm not I could think about
threatening checkmate but then I'll get
checkmated myself alright so so even
though you might be on the attack the
whole time it just takes one move for
for your opponent to try to get a
checkmate here so you always got to be
concerned about your king okay so if
you're just playing your moves like oh
I'm gonna get checkmate here guess what
your king is gonna fall so it's always
watch out for your opponent's attacks
okay Bishop f5 so White has a really
cool move to stop it rook the c4 Queen
to a5 and now so now he's attacking by
pawn here alright but I'm gonna chit I'm
gonna thread my own checkmate here okay
Queen takes check okay well that's what
I should play and that's what I do play
alright so so what's the only way that
black and I black and stop this quaint
well he's got a couple of different ways
of course h5
Oh
check mate so you got to be really
careful how you want to stop this
checkmate okay so h5 does not do the
trick
rook h8 this is Burke h8 do the trick
that doesn't work either so you got to
be really careful yes you got it
Knight takes up six that's yeah child's
play just take it yeah all right so
check know you like play king of h8 all
right we'll play King to h8 that's
actually what what's played in the game
alright let's just keep going for the
throat here we got them on the run I
don't think there is a way we can stop
checkmate here alright so we got the
king in the corner here alright alright
so just hold on hold we have a newly a
newly crowned national master in the
audience here hit firm he always been
doing is going to my beginner breakdown
for five weeks and all of a sudden his
rating is 2362
and that's all he's been doing that's it
just beginner breakdown and now he's now
he's awesome alright so queen two eight
six so what am i threatening Queen to g7
okay so what's the only way black and
stop this checkmate all right rook the
g8 and now we have a very exciting move
in this position
wait for white yep so we're to h4 looks
pretty good but then black plays g5
stopping the checkmate all right so we
got to be quick here we got to be quick
yes Queen takes h7 check very good so he
has to take and now we just yep and then
we just checkmate him you see and he
can't go here
nobody can block and the game would be
over okay
so that's really how you want to play
you want to play pedal-to-the-metal all
right always threaten those checkmates
as long as you're not getting a
checkmated and you'll get him you see
that pretty neat but unfortunately white
played a little a little bad here pawn
takes king to h8 and now he was
concerned about this threat Queen takes
Queen check and then and eventually a
rook check so he played eight a3 to stop
all that and it's too slow rook a to d8
he plays rook to d1 so he should be
thinking about checkmating not not
anything else Queen to e5
well it's not checkmate because the rook
the rook isn't on g8 so Queen takes
pulling in this position is not
checkmate because you can't retreat the
g8 all right Queen to e5 and now white
decides to trade and this is not good
Queen takes h2 and then Queen takes a
seven so so white still has a decent
position but it's not checkmate right
that's what you're after so you got to
make sure that when you have your
opponent on the rope
- checkmate him while you can or else
you're letting black get all this
counter play and probably he'll
eventually uh beat you Queen is as well
see Queen to d6 now he's threatening a
checkmate so we got to stop that now he
gets our pawn and this is no fun for
white anymore left for Bishop e6 attack
sir Brooke Brooke the b4 rook to d4
here take us with check so so now we
have an interesting endgame he's got
three passed pawns I have three passed
pawns
so pretty much whoever does not get
checkmated and whoever turns one of
these into a queen first will probably
win so so this is going to be
interesting
rookie four attacks the our guy Queen to
d3 all right
rook to e3 Queen to d2 I guess we could
be checking but it really it really
wouldn't do us much good to check them
here because they're just poor does King
two back to g7 so so no reason really
checked for no reason
Queen to d2 Queen to e5 but you know
check anyway check see we want to get
something where we will win something
and when we check not just check them
for the sake of checking rook to b8 now
now I would try to get something going
so in this position black tries to get a
trade going so do we have any kind of
check mates here we have a lot of scary
checks but unfortunately none of them
will lead to checkmate we could play
here then he'll go to h6 if we go here
he'll go here so even though all our
checks look pretty scary they don't
actually do anything so white decides
just just trade it off and now he's in a
lot of trouble after rook to e1
or Bishop is now in a pen so what move
must white make here push one of the
puns that's actually what is played in
the game be fork because he really
doesn't have to be concerned about this
because he'll always have King to c1 so
so b4 is what was played so now it's a
race h5 b 5h for B 6 so now black looks
like he's in trouble because because
he's going to be one behind right so he
plays rook to e5 so if white plays b7
rook place check and the rook takes the
point ok so after work to e5 so he's got
to stop this check from happening so he
plays King to c1 but he plays rook to b5
anyway right alright so black plays rook
to d6 protects the pawn King to e7
Bishop e2 the counter attack
so bishop takes and now black makes a
very powerful move here anybody see a
powerful move for black well we have one
one guy thinking he sees a powerful move
all right very good adjourn
my protege coming up with a great move
Bishop the d5 look at that look at that
you're controlling everything
so why pretty much you can just give up
here so a real easy victory for black
after Bishop to d5 all right well thank
you all for coming to a beginner
breakdown hopefully now you know how to
defeat the park defense